>> Sean: JOE BIDEN'S CAMPAIGN
IS IN ALL OUT DAMAGE CONTROL.
THEY HAVE NOW BEEN EXPOSED IN
SPITE OF THE MEDIA MOBS LYING IN
THE CLOUD OF CORRUPTION, AND HIS
FAMILY'S SHADY DEALINGS.
IF WE HAVE BIG BOMBSHELL NEWS
THE MEDIA DOESN'T WANT YOU TO
KNOW.
BIDEN IS IN VERY HOT WATER OVER
WHAT ARE CREDIBLE CLAIMS AND
HE'S ON TAPE WRITING ABOUT IT,
LEVERAGING YOUR TAX DOLLARS,
1 BILLION OF THEM IN YOUR MONEY
TO GET A UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR
FIRED.
WHY WOULD A VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES WANT A
PROSECUTOR IN UKRAINE FIRED?
BECAUSE HE WAS INVESTIGATING HIS
SON AND "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
TIPPED HIM OFF.
THANKS TO NATIONAL REVIEW
ONLINE, THEY HAVE A DETAILED
TIMELINE OF WHAT PRECEDED THIS
BLATANT QUID PRO QUO.
THESE ARE THE FACTS.
IF WE COULD GO BACK AS FAR AS
2007, IT WOULD TAKE THE FULL
HOUR.
WE WILL START ON DECEMBER 4TH
2013.
HUNTER BIDEN JOINED HIS FATHER,
HE MAKES THE TRIP TO ASIA, WHERE
HIS FATHER HAD A MEETING WITH
THE CHINESE PRESIDENT.
THEN IN DECEMBER 2013, LITERALLY
LESS THAN TWO WEEKS LATER,
HUNTER BIDENS COMPANY INKED A
$1 BILLION PRIVATE EQUITY DEAL
WITH A SUBSIDIARY OF THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT BANK OF CHINA.
PETER SCHWEIZER POINTED OUT,
THIS WAS A DEAL UNLIKE ANY OTHER
WESTERN FIRMS GOT.
IT WENT TO HUNTER BIDEN WHO HAD
VIRTUALLY NO EXPERIENCE OR
EXPERTISE IN CHINA OR PRIVATE
EQUITY.
YOU CAN ASK YOURSELF, WHY WOULD
HUNTER BIDEN GET SUCH A
SWEETHEART DEAL?
IT BECAME A BILLION FIVE.
WE HAVE BIG COMPANIES, BIG NAMES
LIKE GOLDMAN SACHS AND
DEUTSCHE BANK, WHY DID THEY
CHOOSE HUNTER BIDEN?
WHAT AREA OF EXPERTISE BRING TO
THE TABLE THAT THEY DIDN'T HAVE?
WHAT DID HE HAVE TO OFFER BEYOND
BEING THE SON OF AMERICA'S
SECOND MOST POWERFUL
DECISION-MAKER?
NOW WE'LL FAST-FORWARD TO
DECEMBER OF 2014, JOE BIDEN
APPOINTED THE POINT PERSON OF
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION IN
UKRAINE, HE WAS IN CONTROL OF
THE UKRAINIAN PORTFOLIO
DIRECTING ALL WESTERN AID
DOLLARS INTO UKRAINE.
A FEW MONTHS LATER,
APRIL 2014 -- JOE BIDEN'S SON
HUNTER SCORED A LUCRATIVE
POSITION ON THE BOARD OF MARISE
MY HOLDINGS AS THE UKRAINIAN
ENERGY OIL, GAS GIANT.
HE WAS PAID A LOT OF MONEY AND
HE HAD NO EXPERIENCE IN OIL,
GAS, ENERGY, OR WITH THE COUNTRY
OF UKRAINE.
GREAT GIG.
IN NOVEMBER OF 2015, HE WAS
ADVISED BY "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
HIS SON HUNTER WAS UNDER
INVESTIGATION BY UKRAINIAN
AUTHORITIES.
IN DECEMBER, HE MADE HIS FIRST
REQUEST TO THE PRESIDENT OF
UKRAINE -- PLEASE FIRE THE
PROSECUTOR THAT HAS LEAD IN THE
CORRUPTION INVESTIGATION INTO MY
SON AND BURISMA HOLDINGS.
IN MARCH 2016, JOHN SOLOMON
REPORTING ON THIS SHOW BIDEN DO
THIS PROSECUTOR WAS
INVESTIGATING HIS SON AND
GETTING AWFULLY CLOSE TO
BRINGING HIM IN FOR QUESTIONING.
THAT'S WHEN BIDEN LEVERAGED A
BILLION DOLLARS IN AID AND
FORCED THE UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT
TO FIRE THE PROSECUTOR.
AS JOE 30330 SAID YOU GOT SIX
HOURS OR YOU'RE NOT GETTING THE
BILLION, SON OF A B -- THEY
FIRED HIM.
PROSECUTORS SIGNED AN AFFIDAVIT,
UNDER THE THREAT OF PERJURY HE
WAS TOLD THIS WAS THE REASON FOR
HIS FIRING, HE TOLD JOHN
SOLOMON, "ABC NEWS," AND
"THE WASHINGTON POST" THE SAME
THING.
WHILE SLEEPY, CREEPY, CRAZY
UNCLE JOE SPINS IT A MILLION
DIRECTIONS TRYING TO CONVINCE
VOTERS HE KNEW NOTHING ABOUT ANY
OF HIS SONS DEALINGS, HIS
INCONVENIENT PICTURE HAS ARISEN,
THAT WOULD BE OF JOE BIDEN,
HUNTER BIDEN GOLFING WITH HIS
PARTNER DEVON ARCHER IN 2014.
REMEMBER ARCHER WAS ALSO ON THE
BOARD, HE WORKED AT ROSEMONT
SENECA WITH HUNTER BIDEN.
THIS PHOTO WAS TAKEN JUST MONTHS
AFTER HUNTER BIDEN TEAMED UP
WITH MARIE       BURISMA HOLDING
WITH MARIE       BURISMA HOLDIN.
THE MEDIA IS LYING TO YOU SAYING
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE.
IF THIS WAS DONALD TRUMP JR.
THERE WOULD BE A TON OF
EVIDENCE.
WHERE'S THE SCRUTINY, I'VE
REPORTED ON THIS SHOW,
JOURNALISM IN AMERICA DIED SINCE
2007 AND PROBABLY BEFORE.
PROFITING OFF THE BIDEN NAME IS
NOT ANYTHING NEW, IT'S BEEN
GOING ON A LONG TIME.
POLITICAL MAGAZINE GOT IT RIGHT
TWICE -- THAT DETAILED HOW IN
2006, HUNTER AND JOE'S YOUNGER
BROTHER JAMES TOOK OVER A FIRM
CALLED PARADIGM GLOBAL ADVISORS.
THEY SOUGHT TO USE THEIR
FATHER'S INFLUENCE TO LINE THEIR
OWN POCKETS, THEIR BROTHER'S
INFLUENCE -- THEY DIDN'T TRY TO
HIDE IT BECAUSE THAT PIECE
QUOTES AN EXECUTIVE AT THE
COMPANY, THE FOLLOWING ABOUT JOE
30330 -- DON'T WORRY ABOUT
INVESTORS, WE GOT PEOPLE ALL
AROUND THE WORLD, THEY WANT TO
INVEST IN JOE BIDEN.
HE IS AN IMPORTANT PERSON IN
GOVERNMENT.
HE VIEWED THE FUND IS A WAY TO
TAKE MONEY FROM RICH FOREIGNERS
WHO CANNOT LEGALLY GIVE MONEY TO
HIS OLDER BROTHER OR HIS
CAMPAIGN ACCOUNT.
WE HAVE INVESTORS LINED UP
FILLED WITH CASH READY TO INVEST
IN THIS COMPANY.
CAN YOU IMAGINE, JUST STOP FOR A
MOMENT FOR ALL WE TOLD YOU.
WHAT IF THE PERSON WAS
DONALD TRUMP JR., ERIN TRUMP   E
DONALD TRUMP JR., ERIN TRUMP   R
DONALD TRUMP JR., ERIN TRUMP   M
DONALD TRUMP JR., ERIN TRUMP   P
DONALD TRUMP JR., ERIN TRUMP   ,
IMAGINE HOW THE MOB AND THE
MEDIA WOULD BE OBSESSED WITH
THAT STORY.
THEY WOULDN'T BE COVERING FOR
DON, JR., THEY WOULD BE FANNING
THE FLAMES.
REMEMBER THIS HYSTERIA OVER THE
TRUMP TOWER MEETING HAD NOTHING
TO DO WITH RUSSIA COLLUSION,
THAT DIDN'T STOP THEM.
THEIR LIES, SMEARS, SLANDER,
MISMANAGEMENT, SPECULATION,
BREATHLESS HYSTERICAL REPORTING.
WE HAVE GOOD NEWS, THE MEDIA MOB
IN SPITE OF WHAT THEY ARE TRYING
TO DO ARE DOING US A HUGE FAVOR
BECAUSE WE'VE KNOWN A LOT OF
THIS FOR A LONG TIME.
IT IS NOW BOOMERANG GANG BACK
ONTO BIDEN AND A SHAKEDOWN OF
U.S. TAXPAYER MONEY THAT HE USED
TO GET THE UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR
FIRED.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE SMART
ENOUGH TO KNOW IF THE NAMES WERE
REVERSED, THAT'S ALL FOR MEDIA
MOB WOULD BE TALKING ABOUT.